bad news russia-related news for Donald
Trump
a bizarre link has been found between a
Trump Organization computer server and a
Russian bank and this is being looked at
by federal investigators and computer
scientists there was an attempt to
dismiss this entire thing months ago but
the investigation is open and in the
purview of the FBI's counterintelligence
team which is the same team looking into
Russian interference during the 2016
presidential election Internet data
points to a computer server that's owned
by a Russia based bank called alpha bank
a LF a repeatedly looking up the contact
data for a computer server used by the
Trump Organization way more frequently
than any other companies did it's
actually overwhelming 80 percent of all
the lookups of this Trump server came
from an alpha bank owned server from May
4 until September 23 of 2016 the Russian
bank looked up the address to this Trump
corporate server over 2,800 times it
gets even stranger when you look at the
second place lookup server 714 lookups
were done by a company called spectrum
health spectrum is a medical facility
chain led by none other than dick DeVos
the husband of now Secretary of
Education Betsy DeVos together alpha
bank and spectrum listen to this
accounted for 99 percent of the server
lookups of this trump server the New
York Times in Slate were the first to
report the unusual server activity and
one US official said that investigators
are finding the connection between a
Trump business server and a Russian bank
server quote odd any time the feds find
anything you've done to be odd it's not
good that I can assure you and according
to a White House official Pat the fact
that this investigation remains open
might actually explain why Trump started
tweeting about Obama wiretapping him in
addition to the propaganda article
published by Breitbart of course yeah I
mean you'd think that the intelligence
community has seen just about everything
at this point you know for them to call
something odd right it's particularly
suspicious the FB
is declining to comment the White House
did not respond to a request for comment
from CNN again not suspicious in and of
itself but what is odd to use the term
that the investigators have used is that
CNN went to some of the different
companies involved and they've come back
with not only a series of different
explanations but explanations that
directly conflict with each other let's
start with the beginning Alpha bank says
hey nothing to see here we can attribute
all of this to spam marketing they say
their executives stayed at Trump hotels
so that these lookups were happening
because Trump hotels was spamming their
executives and the Alpha servers in
response were checking in to where the
spam was coming from which pointed back
to Trump's servers okay
plausible Alpha bank worked with a
company called mediant to look into this
and both were asked ok if you're
claiming that this was a result of spam
marketing emails you got from the Trump
Organization show us one of those emails
received by one of your executives
during the period in question they
weren't able to find a single one of
these emails once again very very odd
another explanation came from a company
called Senden which used to handle
marketing software for this business of
Donald Trump's send in claims this
wasn't two-way communication which would
make it seem like it supports the
marketing claims but Senden admits the
most recent email marketing campaign
that they did for the Trump campaign was
in March of 2016 which is before the
dates in question once again odd odd and
the bigger picture is that even if the
Trump server was being used to spam
people it doesn't explain why a Russian
bank and a company led by Betsy DeVos
his husband received ninety nine percent
of those communications then send and
said okay we've got a new explanation
and it directly conflicts with the first
one it's all mistaken identity send and
said one of our other clients a
different Bank use their event planning
tool called Metron to communicate with
alpha bank okay again it's possible but
it contradicts the first explanation
but then CNN went back to alpha bank
which said 100% hey we've never dealt
with Senden period a couple more days go
by send and then says hey everybody we
now have a third explanation for this
what happened was the Trump Hotel
Collection ditched using Senden and went
with another email marketing company the
German firm called Serenata in March of
2016
sendin said it transferred back to
trump's company the email domain in
question unfortunately Pat that
explanation also fell apart because CNN
went to Sarah nada and Sarah nada said
yeah we were hired by Trump hotels but
we've never used the domain in question
once again there might be nothing here
cybersecurity experts have said this
isn't really how entities would
communicate if they wanted to keep this
secret but we now have five different
conflicting stories from three different
organizations about this right so no
evidence of wrongdoing as of yet but
there seems to be a lot of smoke and I
wouldn't be surprised if sendin and the
other affiliated groups here use their
damage control against their own
interests it kind of just mess
everything up because we've seen that in
the case of Michael Flynn Shore and Jeff
Sessions they're just volunteering
information and giving contradictory
explanations and that in turn ends up
being more damaging to the Trump
reputation if there's some simple and
innocuous explanation here why do we
have five directly contradictory
explanations from three different
entities it doesn't make sense and this
is again not good if you're in the camp
of trying to pretend there's no
connections between RUP Trump and Russia
to be seen send me your thoughts on this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by my
hopscotch I've told many of my stories
before of how much of a pain the car
buying process can be and for many of my
friends the thought of walking into a
car dealership is in and of itself
anxiety-producing and thankfully there
is now help in the form of my hopscotch
comm which is a full
service car buying a website they find
the right car negotiate the price
negotiate your trade-in financing even
warranties if you're interested in that
so that you don't have to my prediction
is that you will be thrilled with their
services but your money back is
guaranteed if you're not you will not
want to buy another car without help
after seeing how much more smooth the
process can be with my hot scotch calm
go to my hopscotch calm and use promo
code David for an extra ten percent off